well let's get more now from ibrahim
he's a senior adviser to
two and spokesman for president erdogan
and joins us live
from the presidential palace in istanbul
thank you so much for joining us
here on al jazeera just explain to us
more why does turkey not want a
diplomatic solution to this crisis
no we support the diplomatic solution
and we call on the men's group actually
to come up with a
timetable with a new proposal that is
actionable
that has specific guidelines to
end the current round of
hostilities but also more importantly to
find a way to end the
occupation of azeri lens by armenia that
has been the root cause of this problem
the men's group which was established
almost 30 years ago has done very little
in fact to
bring an end to this frozen conflict in
the southern caucasus at its time
really to come up with a new proposal
new road map that's what the azeri's
have been demanding that's what we've
been supporting
yes to assist fire by the ceasefire must
be sustainable and the only way to make
it sustainable
is also to talk about ending the
armenian occupation of azeri lens
as you know uh karabakh nagorno-karabakh
is
is the land of the azerbaijan state of
azerbaijan according to u.n decisions
according to numbers
of number of resolutions osc decision
etc
so yes to a diplomatic solution but that
that needs to come up with
or combined with a a timetable with the
roadmap that will bring an end to the
occupation of nagorno-karabakh by
armenia so do you support then the
efforts of the french russian and u.s
representatives who are heading to
geneva to start
thrashing out a road map
if they're calling only for a cisfar
working just on a ceasefire it will be
nothing more than a repeat of what
went on over the last 30 years or so uh
it
it is almost certain to fail if it
doesn't
also involve a detailed uh
plan to end the occupation and
yes we want this clashes to come to an
end we don't want any civilians or
others to be hurt
in this conflict uh too many people have
already lost their lives uh more than a
million azeri
people had to flee nagorno-karabakh in
the 1990s when armenia occupied
this part of azerbaijan yes we want an
end to all of this human suffering the
fighting
this conflict in the southern caucasus
but if the miss group is to be credible
and if they're going to claim any
political and moral authority at this
point to bring an end to this conflict
they must also start
a serious work on ending the occupation
and
what's turkey's role here why exactly is
is turkey taking such a a strong
position in this particular conflict
well for two reasons southern uh
caucuses uh you know what happens there
of course is of direct concern to us
uh it affects uh you know our borders it
affects our uh
uh our region uh our relationship with
azerbaijan with georgia and the larger
caucasus region that's number one number
two we have a very special relationship
with azerbaijan you know we call
ourselves one nation two states
and we have a long-standing uh military
agreement
with azerbaijan in addition to many
other cultural economic political
diplomatic
agreements with azerbaijan um and we
would like to see
an end to this occupation of azeri lens
you keep saying this as an occupation
about this cause we believe
i'm sorry to cut you off there you keep
saying this is an occupation but this
isn't these people
these people have been living there this
goes this predates 1990
uh for predates the the the the late 80s
these people have been living their
generations have been living there
decades the schools you could argue this
goes back to the
the soviet days in the ussr
i think you're referring to the armenian
population of nagorno-karabakh
that's a fact that they've been living
there together with the azeries for for
many decades under the soviet republic
rule that is true
and the azares have always said that you
know once nagorno-karabakh is liberated
those armenians who live there will live
under uh you know just like you know any
other uh
uh citizens they will be entitled to
their rights uh they will have their
freedom of religion
culture identity and and so on so forth
yes it is occupation according to all
the young resolutions just like the
israeli occupation of the palestinian
lands there is no legal or political
debate about that it's a fact
so so is turkey going to stay involved
in this
until the armenians
leave the region of nagorno-karabakh
until
armenians pull out completely pull all
their citizens who've been living there
for decades is that
your dividing line turkey stays engaged
in this fight until that happens
no no one has called for civilian
armenians to leave nagorno-karabakh
if once uh in fact when uh once
nagorno-karabakh is liberated and
becomes part of azerbaijan again those
who
live there armenian citizens i'm uh i
mean
of course they will be allowed they will
have the rights to stay there because
they've been living there for many years
as i said in the past before the
armenian occupation the azeries and
armenians were living together
but let's not forget the fact that more
than a million azeri's had to flee
nagorno-karabakh after uh the the
armenian occupation and about uh
as far as remember about 30 plus
thousand almost 40 000 people died over
the last 30 years we do not want to see
a repeat
just want to get indeed how deeply
turkey is involved in this because there
have been allegations that turkey is
sending troops at sending syrians via
turkey
into this fight supplying arms to the
azeries
it appears that turkey is very very
invested in this
at a time when you're already um
fighting with nato members and disputes
with nato members in the eastern
mediterranean
getting involved in libya now it appears
there is a third front there
happening in the caucasus i mean are you
worried that turkey
is spreading itself a bit too thin
fighting on too many fronts
well first of all there is no evidence
of the so-called syrian fighters going
fighters going to uh
to azerbaijan or facilitated by us but
there
there is evidence of lebanese armenian
uh individuals i guess or militia
you know going there i mean they're
posing before cameras and saying calling
openly
you know for a holy war or something
again well the french president and the
syrian president
say that's not nonsense
the french president the syrian
president have said there are syrians
being created
can you take
they are not good references really when
it comes to facts uh either the
syrian president or the french president
i'm not sure because we've had to deal
with them in the past
on many different occasions uh but i
know the french position you know they
oppose
uh turkey almost on every single issue
of
strategic significance in syria in libya
and we believe
france is on the on the wrong side of
history i mean in
in syria france supports members of pkk
which is a terrorist organization listed
as a terrorist organization
in the eu in france and other places uh
in libya france supports haftar
who is supported by russia and france is
a nato member i don't know how it
reconciles
this with uh you know with being a
member of nato and
talking about the uh the security and
safety of the southern flank of uh
of nato in in north africa uh etc i mean
they're all
complicated issues uh there but you know
our main concern
is to find a diplomatic solution to this
but as i said
for this piece to be sustainable or
ceasefire to be sustainable it needs to
be
based on a roadmap a plan to end the
occupation
that that will be the only way to solve
this problem so that we don't have to
repeat this for the next 30 years
okay ibrahim khalid i'm afraid we are
out of time but thank you so much
for joining us from the presidential
palace in istanbul abraham kaleen
a senior adviser to the turkish
president recep tay pardon thank you